feilschen hinter masken ein neuer
vorschlag bringt bewegungen die
milliardenschweren verhandlungen beim
eu-sondergipfel gemeinsam fürs fahren
tausende protestieren in nürnberg gegen
mögliche fahrverbot an sonn und
feiertagen flammen in der kathedrale von
mount mieter verursacht ein feuer große
schäden an einer französischen kirche
die ermittler gehen von brandstiftung
aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen am
samstag bei den zdf-nachrichten die vom
sport hat heute rudi cerne dabei unter
anderem mit der formel1 guten abend und
wir schauen zu beginn nach brüssel zum
eu sondergipfel wo es weiter um viele
milliarden an corinna hilfen geht doch
die sogenannten sparsamen vier um die
niederlande herum wollen den
notleidenden südländern geld nicht ohne
bedingungen zukommen lassen
darauf ist staatspräsident michel jetzt
eingegangen mit einem
kompromissvorschlag
selten hatten die bilder von einem
eu-gipfel mehr symbolkraft 27 länder
reden zwar miteinander aber unter
schwierigsten vorzeichen
noch gestern abend soll die lage völlig
verfahren gewesen sein und jede einigung
in weiter ferne doch jetzt mit dem neuen
vorschlag ist wieder bewegung drin
und gleich eine frage an anne gellinek
vorab hat sich dadurch denn die stimmung
in brüssel etwas verbessert ja das kann
man so sagen gestern abend bei einem
späten essen der staats und
regierungschefs muss es noch mal richtig
laut geworden seien am gipfeltisch
mehrere teilnehmer beschrieben die
stimmung als angespannt und sogar als
ruppig nach dem neuen
kompromissvorschlag dann heute ist eine
ruhige arbeitsatmosphäre eingekehrt aber
ob das reicht um die noch offenen fragen
zu lösen
das ist im moment unklar über die
ereignisse des zweiten gipfeltages
berichtet mein kollege luc vpod die
laune war aufgeräumt heute früh als die
gipfelteilnehmer wieder zusammentragen
gestern abend war es angesichts der
festgefahrenen positionen etwas rauer
zugegangen bulgariens regierungschef
boris software auf dem niederländischen
kollegen rückte vor der spiele sich auf
wie europas polizist rüttel ficht das
nicht an
wir haben natürlich ein interesse daran
sehr deutlich klar zu machen wo wir an
den vor allem wenn es um so viel geld
gehe
ratspräsident michelle legte einen neuen
vorschlag auf den tisch der bewegung in
die verhandlungen bringen soll
der 750 milliarden euro wiederaufbau
fonds soll jetzt fast gleichviel kredite
und bei
enthalten außerdem mit einer art
notbremse eingebaut legt ein
mitgliedstaat bedenken ein kann die
auszahlung der mittel verzögert oder
gestoppt werden um die blockierer
umzustimmen werden österreich dänemark
und schweden höhere rabatte auf deren
eu-haushalts zahlungen gewährt und der
anteil der mitgliedstaaten an den
gemeinsamen eu zolleinnahmen wird erhöht
viele andere fragen sind noch offen vor
allem die kopplung von eu-zahlungen an
die einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher
standards was von ungarns
ministerpräsident orban vehement
abgelehnt wird er droht mit veto für den
fall dass es doch noch ein langer abend
wird stärkten sich die regierungschefs
von wegen luxemburg und malta schon mal
mit belgischen fritten ja und eine
zahlen müssen wir korrigieren es geht um
300 milliarden kredit und um 450
milliarden an beihilfe die fritten
bessern sicher die stimmung trotzdem ist
noch vieles offen an
ist denn grundsätzlich die chance auf
einigung nun größer geworden
michelle der gipfel-chef hat versucht
mit seinem neuen kompromissvorschlag die
selbsternannten sparsamen einzufangen
indem er ihnen entgegengekommen ist aber
das birgt zwei neue gefahren erstens
sind die sparsamen mit den kürzungen die
bislang erreicht wurden noch nicht
zufrieden
und zweitens besteht die gefahr dass er
mit den neuen kürzungen wiederum die
südeuropäer verprellt außerdem ist die
frage ob die eu 27 beim thema
rechtsstaatlichkeit eine gemeinsame
position finden können und wie ernstes
viktor orban eigentlich mit dem
angedrohten veto meint wenn es um die
kürzungen von eu-mitteln geben dazu
kommt noch ein berg von kleinen
detailfragen und das ist die frage im
moment verhandeln die staats und
regierungschefs noch in kleingruppen und
erst wenn sie heute abend im plenum
wieder zusammenkommen dann werden sie
entscheiden ob es sich lohnt die ganze
nacht noch weiter zu verhandeln oder ob
man sich besser vertagt auf einen
weiteren gipfel ende juli
sie bleiben dran für uns vielen dank an
die klinik nach brüssel das corona virus
breitet sich weiter rasant aus die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat einen
rekordstand bei den neuinfektionen
vermeldet welt
weit 238.000 innerhalb von 24 stunden
auch in deutschland steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen aber auf niedrigem niveau
im schnitt der letzten sieben tage haben
sich täglich 390 menschen neu angesteckt
gestern lag die zahl noch bei 350 in
israel ist corona seit wochen wieder auf
dem vormarsch gleichzeitig ächzt die
wirtschaft nur keine schließungen mehr
fordern nicht nur unternehmer was aber
tun um einen kollaps der kliniken und
womöglich viele weitere corinna tote zu
vermeiden
israels regierung hat regelungen
speziell für die wochenenden beschlossen
die kanal brecht berichtet ab in den
knast netanjahu skandieren sie mit wut
im bauch und tränen in den augen direkt
vor der residenz des premierministers in
jerusalem
es ist einer der landesweiten nunmehr
täglichen und immer heftiger werdenden
proteste gegen den umgang der regierung
mit der korona krise wir haben genug wir
wollen nicht mehr die sklaven der
regierung seien mal lockdown mal kein
lockdown ich musste mein geschäft
schließen
ich habe alle angestellten gefeiert und
wir sitzen alle zu hause ohne geld 22
prozent arbeitslosigkeit durch die
pandemie die wirtschaft am boden
netanya verspricht soforthilfen
umgerechnet knapp 200 euro soll jeder
bürger erhalten
das geld wird die leute dazu bringen
wieder zu konsumieren und ab dem moment
wo gekauft wird werden geschäfte wieder
florieren lächerliches schweigegeld
nennen es kritiker die neuinfektionen
will die regierung durch einen wochenend
lockdown eindämmen geschäfte
schwimmbäder museen und
touristenattraktionen müssen ab sofort
und bis auf weiteres freitags und
samstags schließen
wird diese pläne vor tabelle 2
nicht durch klar dass man sich damals
mehr
[Musik]
in diesen minuten macht sich schon
wieder die ersten unzufriedenen bürger
auf den weg zur nächsten großdemo in
london sorgt ein video einer
polizeiaktion für empörung
scotland yard spricht von extrem
verstörenden aufnahmen
es werden erinnerungen wach an den tod
von georgia in den usa ende mai der
durch polizeigewalt ums leben kam
die aufnahmen zeigen zwei polizisten die
einen schwarzen gewaltsam zu boden
drücken
passanten mischen sich lautstark ein sie
fordern die beamten auf den mann los zu
lassen
der vorfall soll sich bereits am
donnerstag abgespielt haben
einer der polizisten wurde inzwischen
suspendiert der andere versetzt
nach china seit ende juni regnet es in
teilen des landes fast ununterbrochen
die folge verheerende überschwemmungen
besonders betroffen ist das
einzugsgebiet entlang des flusses
jangtse mehr als 140 menschen sollen
bereits ums leben gekommen seien ganze
landstriche stehen unter wasser
millionen existenzen sind bedroht und
fremder berichtet in china sozialen
medien gibt es einen ungefilterten blick
auf die flutkatastrophe ganze städte
entlang des ganzen saufen ab denn chinas
längstem fluss haben die regenfälle
dramatisch anschwellen lassen
mehr als 18 4 millionen menschen sind
betroffen fürchten um ihr hab und gut
wie er schenkt dessen ernte die flut
zerstört hat wir versuchen teile der
ernte zu trocken um sie zu retten und
den ganzen rest müssen wir wegschmeißen
in chinas staatssenders cctv werden
helden geschichten erzählt der kampf
gegen die flut als eine nationale
aufgabe
die einsatzkräfte schütten deiche wieder
auf versuchen jeden zu retten
wir bereiten material vor damit wir im
notfall handeln können um den nächsten
dann zu sichern
vor allem der drei-schluchten-staudamm
läuft voll
in den vergangenen zehn tagen ist der
wasserstand um zwölf meter gestiegen
dadurch wird der druck auf den staudamm
immer stärker immer mehr wasser wird
abgelassen was die flut noch
verschlimmert keine guten nachrichten
für die rettungskräfte
wir versuchen uns gegen die flut zu
schützen wie errichten zusätzliche dämme
damit wir möglichst wenige opfer haben
es soll weiter regnen der ganze soll
weiter ansteigen
chinas größter fluss bedroht millionen
von menschen vor zwei monaten hat der
bundesrat entschieden motorradlärm ist
ein ernstes problem
es muss etwas dagegen unternommen werden
seitdem liegt der ball bei der
bundesregierung und seitdem sind die
motorradfahrer alarmiert
[Musik]
rund vier millionen gibt es in
deutschland manche von ihnen unterwegs
mit manipulierten maschinen und mehr als
100 dezibel das entspricht etwa einem
presslufthammer auf 80 dezibel soll der
lärm gedrückt werden mehrere maßnahmen
sind dafür im gespräch
übertrieben meinen die fahrer peter
meyer berichtet sie machen jeden samstag
mobil wie hier in nürnberg tausende von
motorradfahrern die demonstrieren weil
sie sich in ihren rechten bedroht sehen
es darf nicht sein dass man mir am
wochenende eingeschränkt werden und
beschränkt werden sagt ja wenn man die
bestehenden gesetze die es gibt einfach
besser kontrolliert wir haben das gute
recht motorrad zu fahren wo wir wollen
und wann wir wollen wenn es nach dem
bundesrat geht soll motorräder leiser
werden härtere strafen für
manipulationen am auspuff und in
besonderen konfliktfällen auch zeitlich
beschränkte verkehrsverbote am sonn und
feiertage sollen dabei helfen
es gibt einfach bestimmte gegenden wo
anwohner seit 20 jahren darum kämpfen
dass ihm einen ruhigen abend im sommer
haben und dort ein kompromiss zu finden
und beispielsweise sozusagen diese eine
strecke sperren weil nichts anderes
geholfen hat weil keine schilder
geholfen haben weil keine westhafen
geholfen haben weil keine
polizeikontrollen geholfen habe das
fände ich schon einfach ok in den
vergangenen jahren ist nicht nur die
zahl der zugelassenen motorräder
gestiegen sondern auch der geräuschpegel
der fahrzeuge bestimmte motorrad
hersteller bieten sogar so genanntes
sounddesigner
es ist einfach zu nimmt deswegen
eskaliert weil motorrad derweil
motorrädern vor lauter geworden sind und
zwar legal und das ist in den letzten
zehn jahren sehr sehr massiv geworden
die politik muss jetzt auch ein
deutliches signal setzen dass man ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren auf den weg
bringen damit motorräder und fahrzeuge
insgesamt ab werk leiser werden die
proteste sollen weitergehen schon am
kommenden wochenende ein großer schreck
heute morgen in frankreich rauch steigt
auf aus dem inneren der kathedrale von
nord es brennt in dem gotischen
gotteshaus und in frankreich werden
schlimme erinnerungen wach das feuer in
der kathedrale von notre dame
letztes jahr hat sich in das kollektive
gedächtnis eingebrannt
doch anders als in paris können die
feuerwehrleute enorm den schaden wohl in
grenzen halten
thomas walde kirchen fenster zerbarsten
flammen drangen nach außen 60
feuerwehrleute brauchten mehrere stunden
bis sie den brand in der gotischen
kathedrale von nord unter kontrolle
hatten und die schäden begutachten
konnten die große orgel scheint völlig
zerstört und auch das podest auf denen
sie stand und nun prüfen wir ob
kunstwerke beschädigt wurden durch den
rauch
erste ermittlungen ergaben dass drei
feuer ausbrachen eines im ersten stock
auf hürde auge und eines auf jeder seite
des kirchenschiffs drei brandherde lässt
uns von brandstiftung ausgehen das ist
kein unfall
wir haben heute morgen ein
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet wegen
der besonderen bedeutung der kathedrale
kamen am nachmittag kultur innen und der
premierminister nach nord ich möchte
mich vor allem herzlich bedanken für den
aufopferungsvollen und professionellen
einsatz der hundertschaft feuerwehrleute
die sofort nach brandausbruch
mobilisiert wurden gebäude wie die
kathedrale von nord gehören in
frankreich dem staat sie zählen zum
kulturerbe des landes urlaub in
deutschland das ist ein trend den
hoteliers und würde gerne sehen es kommt
wieder geld in die kasse aber was ist
mit orten in denen vor corona er
amerikaner und asiaten zu gast waren
in rüdesheim am rhein peter theißen hat
dort nachgefragt
die drosselgasse zumindest am wochenende
wieder einigermaßen belebt dennoch die
gasthäuser in rutesheim leiden schwer
denn es fehlen die ausländischen
touristen
dieses jahr geht es uns gar nicht darum
geld zu verdienen uns geht es darum alle
löhne zahlen zu können wenn es hoch
kommt auch noch eine rate zahlen zu
können
aber es geht dieses jahr wirklich darum
das jahr zu überstehen übernachten kann
man hier sogar im weinfass doch gerade
mal zu 40 prozent ist das hotel
ausgelastet ein hoffnungsschimmer es
kommen immer mehr wanderer und
radtouristen aus deutschland ich denke
dass es jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
lehrer ist und das genießt man natürlich
gerade wenn man auch morgens unterwegs
ist sonst wenn man als tagesausflügler
kommt dann ist man ja mittags geht man
durch die vollen gassen und jetzt war es
noch schön leer doch rutesheim leidet 13
bis 14 millionen euro hat die
tourismusbranche alleine während des lok
downs verloren und auch das stadtsäckel
leert sich
schätzungen gehen von zwei bis drei
millionen allein und gewerbesteuer die
wir verlieren aus und wir müssen dann
gucken wie wir das ganze kompensieren
kommen können es gibt im moment sehr
viele lippenbekenntnisse von land und
vom bund und beschriftet ich habe ich
noch nichts also bevor ich nicht was
wirklich in der tasche habe kann ich mir
jetzt nicht sicher sein wie wir die
nächsten haushalte jetzt bestücken
können
rüdesheim zwischen bangen und hoffen auf
die neuen urlaubstrends zum sport und
sohu die da kommen auch heute wieder ein
formel 1 weltmeister lewis hamilton
da führt kein weg dran vorbei oder eine
klasse für sich der mann lewis hamilton
stellt seinen mercedes dort ab wo er
üblicherweise zu finden ist ganz vorne
der sechsmalige weltmeister fährt eben
qualifying beim großen preis von ungarn
erneut auf startplatz eins leichter
aufwärtstrend bei ferrari sebastian
vettel startet morgen von platz fünf ins
rennen
die 90 position für lewis hamilton der
weltmeister so erfolgsverwöhnt dass es
kaum noch zum jubeln taugt sein mercedes
läuft wie auf schienen teamkollegen
valtteri bottas nur knapp hinter
hamilton auf rang zwei der rest der
konkurrenz weit entfernt sebastian
vettel im ferrari mit leichtem
aufwärtstrend auf rang fünf immerhin
schneller als sein stall rivale fahne
kling insgesamte wie gesagt ist
natürlich schon deutlich besser und ich
hoffe dass sich das auch morgen
fortsetzt ernst roll und sergio perez
auf den plätzen drei und vier deren team
racing point vielleicht vettels nächster
arbeitgeber lewis hamilton rückt einmal
mehr den anspruch als nummer 1 zu recht
lisa-marie choir sorgt für die
top-leistung beim vortest einiger der
besten sprinterinnen deutschlands in
wetzlar
dabei gewinnt die berlinerin ganz rechts
über 100 meter in persönlicher bestzeit
von 11,2 einzelkunden von jennifer
montag aus leverkusen
damit verbessert sie ihre eigene
deutsche jahresbestzeit um fünf
hundertstelsekunden
weltweit waren bisher in diesem sommer
nur vier sprinterinnen schneller nach
der olympia absage sind die deutschen
meisterschaften in drei wochen in
braunschweig der saisonhöhepunkt und
dominic thiem steht im finale des tennis
einladungsturniers auf dem ehemaligen
flughafen tempelhof in berlin gegen
tommy haas setzt sich der
weltranglisten-dritte im duell der
generationen in zwei sätzen durch
haas der mit seinen 42 jahren lange zeit
auf augenhöhe mit ihm spielt imponiert
durch seine energieleistung dem weiteren
verlauf kann haas der mit problemen am
linken oberschenkel kämpft nicht mehr
mithalten team gewinnt mit 7 zu 6 6 3
und trifft morgen auf den südtiroler
jannik sinne
das war es vom sport der sonntag startet
mit viel sonne und es wird auch richtig
war nachmittags drohen allerdings
gewitter wo das erfahren wir gleich von
katja honnefer so viel von uns danke für
ihr interesse
bettina schausten erwartet sie heute
erst um 22 uhr 45 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr einen entspannten
samstagabend wünschen wird schiss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
ähnlich wie heute ziehen auch morgen von
westen einige wolken bände heran und
dieser wolken kringel über österreich
bringt schwimmen feuchte luft in den
osten deutschlands
jetzt in der nacht fällt den bayerischen
wald etwas regen sonst ist es häufig
klar und das bildet sich auch mal nebel
bei 17 bis 8 grad
morgen vormittag strahlt die sonne von
der ostseeküste bis zum bodensee am
bayerischen wald sind die wolken dichter
und auch im nordwesten dort kann es dann
spätestens am nachmittag auch regnen
und dann gibt es diese kleinen räumen
heftigen gewitter zum beispiel im
südlichen brandenburg in sachsen oder
auch in niederbayern
die temperaturen klettern morgen auf 25
bis 30 grad nur an der nordsee und am
alpenrand bleibt es kühler
am montag überquert norddeutschland eine
kaltfront danach geht es sommerlich
weiter die gewitter beschränken sich auf
die alpen
auch in freiburg im breisgau kann es in
der nächsten zeit gewitter geben
die temperaturen liegen im
hochsommerlichen bereich zwischen 25 und
30 grad in frankfurt sind es um die 25
grad in dresden sind sie niedriger die
temperaturen steigen dann aber wieder an
aber in rostock damit es richtig kalt am
mittwoch liegen die höchsttemperaturen
dort nur noch bei 17 grad
schönen abend noch